watch this experiment it's called the
McGurk effect
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba what do you think
he's saying if you think he's saying da
da da you are in the grand majority but
now close your eyes and listen instead
of watching bah bah bah bah bah bah bah
the voice is saying bah bah bah
now let's replay it without the sound
yes it's true his lips are saying gagaga
so how is it that when the lips are
saying gah gah gah
and the sound says bah bah bah that our
brains read dah dah dah the McGurk
effect it's an example of an auditory
illusion it's a great way to show that
the accurate perception of information
can involve the participation of more
than one sensory system in this case
vision with sound we call it multimodal
perception the McGurk effect
it's a terrific example of the fact that
the senses did not evolve in isolation
from each other but actually work
together to help us perceive our world
when multiple senses are stimulated
simultaneously the brain begins to
experience an information rich learning
experience and lapse it up like ice
cream it encodes more information per
unit time and it remembers that
information better too